grand colombia doesn't exist at least
not anymore it was a formidable country
in south america that contained what are
now colombia venezuela panama ecuador as
well as parts of peru and brazil it
lasted for the sum total of 12 years
before rapidly falling apart but why did
this major nation break up why did grand
colombia fail to begin we have to go
back to napoleon it's always napoleon
spain had allied with him which brought
it into conflict with britain and
portugal whose navies hampered the
ability of the spanish monarchy to
communicate with its american holdings
the spanish king was soon overthrown by
napoleon and thereafter those who lived
in spanish america took governing into
their own hands since spain's new king
were seen as illegitimate across the
spanish empire civil wars broke out
between those who wished to stay loyal
to spain under its new king and those
who wish for independence one place
trying to break away was venezuela which
some chap called simone bolivar had been
fighting to liberate for half a decade
at this point in order to secure his
country's independence bolivar needed to
make sure that spanish and royalist
forces couldn't take refuge in the
bordering regions of what was called the
viceroyalty of new granada and so in
1819 bolivar chased down spanish forces
there he defeated them and politicians
back in venezuela declared the creation
of the republic of colombia which look
like this incidentally this country is
referred to as gran colombia to separate
it from what's now colombia so what
happened well the first issue was that
bolivar wasn't done and he was busy
driving the spanish out of the rest of
south america doing so was very
expensive and funding this was made even
harder by the corruption across grand
columbia furthermore as his campaign was
ongoing he kept getting made president
of more and more countries which he soon
gave up to his close friends because
these friends were on the same page as
him and would totally give up their
newfound power to enlarge gran colombia
in the future when he asked another
issue was that simply declaring an area
to be a united state doesn't make it so
under the spanish each part of the
viceroyalty was administered separately
and had little interaction with the
others and now that they had to get
along they didn't and similar to those
in the early united states the people in
grand columbia are identified with their
state much more than their country so
why did one succeed when the other
failed well it's because bolivar wanted
gran colombia to be heavily centralized
as opposed to being a federation of
semi-autonomous states bolivar feared
that without a strong central government
grand colombia would fall to civil war
quickly and so he built a government in
which power lay mostly within the
capital and the other major cities would
only have limited authority which of
course caused resentment in response
bolivar called for a constitutional
convention the plan was that everyone
would agree to his vision for the
country but instead everybody wanted
gran colombia to be a federation and if
these local powers couldn't be upheld
separation bolivar refused to accept any
of this and he wanted to be made
president for life with broad powers to
stop the country from fracturing
literally nobody wanted this and so in
1830 when he realized he had failed
bolivar quit he died shortly afterwards
but not until after ecuador and
venezuela had declared their
independence and thus grand colombia had
fractured into three new nations and
bolivar's dream of the united
spanish-speaking south america was dead
i hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker mr wolfe sky
chappelle adam stalter jordan longley
rod d martin gareth turner wyan hockey
jerry lamdin spencer lightfoot corso
wolff boogerly wiggly marvin kassar
winston k wood gustav swan marcus asner
captain cydog aaron the white matthew
shipley robert wetzel alex schwinn
maggie paxkowski the mc wapper anthony
beckett coppertone spinning through
plates charles the first ben evanson
scottish trekkie and words about books
podcast